>>Student: Wait should I clear out this?
>>Jodi: I numbered the
lines in your tribute poems.
When somebody is giving you feedback,
they can name the specific line number.
>>Student: I like stanza one, because it
has really strong figurative language.
>>Jessica: Because our students
participate in critique protocol,
they have the opportunity to really
understand what quality looks like,
and to define for themselves their
expectations for achieving it.
>>Elaine: Starting as early as
preschool, the culture of revision
and of learning together is
better, is what sets up students
to be very proficient in their
ability to receive critical feedback
and to give critical feedback.
>>Anne: I have a couple
of your friends' work.
>>Sylvia: Today in class
we looked at our work
to see if we could fix anything.
>>What are our rules
when we are critiquing
and making our friends' work better.
Yes?
>>Don't feel like, "I hate your work."
>>Very good.
We should always be...?
>>Kind.
>>Yes.
>>Jessica: The rules of critique,
be kind, be specific and be helpful,
apply to all of the work
we do with critique.
>>Anne: First we're going
to look at Jessica's work.
>>We looked at one student's work.
The task itself was to use measurement
descriptions to order a number
of animals, like insects and arachnids.
>>So she read that it was half the
weight of the rose haired tarantula.
>>We looked at her work and we talked
about, wow, how is this really strong?
>>What did Jessica do?
>>Student: She drew pictures
and she labeled them.
>>Anne: Interesting.
>>Jonas: You can learn more about it
and you're teaching others
about what you learned.
>>Anne: What could she do
to make that even clearer?
>>The way that I think about a
critique is, it's back and forth.
I'm going to give you some feedback on
how you can make your work more clear,
but I'm also getting
really good ideas from you.
>>Student: She could put...
>>Anne: Things that are...
>>Student: Lighter and the
top, and write the things
that she needed to write up there.
>>Anne: It shows them
that, no matter what,
people should learn from their work.
You can learn from other people's work
and there's always the
potential to make it even better.
>>And what are the measurement words?
>>Students: Lighter and heavier.
>>Jessica: I think there are a number of
ways that you could approach critique.
One is to use a high quality piece
of work and have kids observe it
and make comments about it.
And then there's peer to peer critique.
>>Student: I feel like we need to add
a little bit more rhyming scheme to it.
>>Marcus: I've been doing critiques
since my first year at Two Rivers.
In seventh grade, you're on
a deeper level of critiquing.
You're like, more specific.
>>Jodi: Marcus, what are we doing today?
>>Marcus: I can give
and receive feedback
to improve my peers' tribute
and my group's tribute.
>>Jodi: Okay, so think about the guiding
question of, how can this poem show
and describe rather than just tell?
>>Having a very detailed, concrete
structure really makes sure
that students sit with
the work and analyze it.
>>Wynne: So my tribute poem is
on the real story of slavery.
My poem's in draft three.
We're getting critique right now so we
can move onto draft four and eventually,
I believe, draft five
will be our final product.
>>Student: I still think throughout
the poem, you should give like,
more detail about like,
who she was, because--
>>Marcus: I know that by the hard work,
I'll end up with a really
high quality piece,
because my friends are here to help me.
>>Student: We need to
make a stronger ending.
>>Jessica: You're asking
them to do a lot more work.
You're asking them to keep thinking,
and you're basically changing the idea
of what it means to be
done with something.
>>Student: It adds flow.
>>Student: Okay.
>>Elaine: Our students work very
hard here at Two Rivers to ensure
that their craftsmanship is really
on point, to best convey their ideas.
And their ability to participate in
critique just gets better and better.
>>Jodi: See, you just came
up with a great suggestion.